bonjour alors il ya quelques années dans
la bibliothèque de mes parents j'ai
trouvé une encyclopédie et dans cette
encyclopédie il y avait des images
d'étoilés de planètes et j'ai été
tellement touché par la beauté de ces
objets célestes que je me suis dit plus
tard j'aimerais travailler avec et en
fait je devais avoir 7 ou 8 ans et je ne
savais pas encore mais je venais de
définir leurs rêves
ma passion et mon objectif principal du
coup j'ai suivi un cursus scientifique
normal qui n'a fait que me conforter
dans ce rêve de devenir astronome et
j'ai beaucoup appris et également
pendant toutes ces années et j'ai appris
sur la beauté de notre système solaire
le soleil la terre les comètes etc
ça va bientôt faire 60 ans que l'homme a
commencé à explorer l'espace et pour ça
ils envoyaient des sondes qui n'ont
sillonné et qui nous ont rapporté deux
magnifiques donné et aujourd'hui grâce à
ces sondes
on peut rouler sur la planète mars pour
tenter de percer les mystères de son
passé et on peut également se poser sur
une comète pour essayer de déchiffrer
notre passé est là en ce moment même il
ya de nouvelles missions spatiales qui
sont en train d'être développé pour
aller encore plus loin et qui nous ouvre
également des perspectives encore plus
fabuleuse et par exemple il ya une
émission qui s'appelle de james webb
space telescope ou hst est un télescope
spatial
ce qui veut dire qu'il se rendrait dans
l'espace pour sillonner l'univers et qui
devrait décoller en 2018 et se
télescopent a été développée par la nasa
l'agencé spatiale européenne et l'agencé
spatiale canadienne
ce télescope pour a pour mission de
répondre à quelques questions telles que
comment se sont formés les galaxies
comment se sont formés les galaxies les
étoiles des planètes et comment chaque
eu à évoluer
on peut se demander à quoi ça sert de
répondre à toutes ces questions et bien
saviez vous que qu'un être humain est
cependant est ce que pense ce qu'on peut
appeler un assemblage de poussière des
toiles parce que les éléments qui nous
composent ce sont les mêmes qu'on
retrouve au coeur d'une étoile et donc
explorer l'espace c'est aussi tenter de
comprendre qui nous sommes et notre
place dans cet univers
en 2008 l'agencé spatiale européenne a
lancé un appel à candidature pour
devenir astronaute
je vous en reparle parce que j'avais
commencé à faire mon dossier est en gros
pour devenir astronaute il faut avoir
des compétences scientifiques techniques
parlez anglais couramment
bon le russe c'est une option il s'est
quand même bien de le parler est
également avoir des qualités humaines
à l'époque j'avais la vingtaine je
n'avais même pas encore terminé mon
master donc je n'avais pas beaucoup
d'expérience professionnelle et en plus
quand j'ai vu les qualités humaines
demandé pour un astronaute je me suis
dit d'accord je vais y travailler et
après je reviens donc du coup je suis
pas allé jusqu'au bout en fait de mon
dossier de candidature mais bon j'espère
que la chance parce européenne compte
entrouvrir cet appel dans pas trop
longtemps parce que je vieillis
et donc du coup pour me former et être
encore meilleur je suis parti un an plus
tard dans un centre de la nasa pour
suivre une formation
cette formation en fait qui était
proposée par l'international space
university avait pour objectif de nous
inculquer plusieurs notions pour
retrouve dans le domaine du spatial
par exemple des cours d'astrobiologie
également des cours dans le train
spatial et un jour je suis parti aux
cours d'ingénierie spatiale
en gros vous expliquer voilà on voit des
satellites autour de la terre et grâce à
ses satellites on a accès au gps
internet aux télécommunications etc
et après ce court j'ai eu un cours va
vers le mans spatiale environnement
spatial c'est la première fois que
j'entendais ce terme est ce qu'on vous a
été donné par rudy gay riels ingénieur à
l'agencé spatiale européenne que je
remercie aujourd'hui car m'étais
découvrir une très belle thématiques et
j'ai découvert une compétence qu'un
homme mais vraiment je pense que c'est
ce lettres sur terre qui a fait mon pète
ans c'est de laisser une trace de son
passage partout où il va
tu lui d'aller sur la lune tu
retrouveras des traces de vie c'est
clair et net
et donc là trace qu'il a laissée dans
l'espace c'est si ça fonctionne des
déchets ceci n'est pas un atome c'est
notre planète la terre entouré de débris
spatiaux
donc c'est comme ça qu'on appelle des
déchets qu'on y trouve et leur taille a
été augmenté en fait de manière à mieux
entrevoir leur densité
donc aujourd'hui on à peu près 20 milles
d'evry qui ont une faille supérieure à
10 cm sept cent mille pour une taille
qui varie de 1 à 10 cm et 125 millions
qui ont une taille inférieure à 1 mm à
l'époque un des arguments pour dire que
c'est pas très grave
c'était de dire l'espace c'est grand
c'est infini oui mais le problème c'est
que des satellites des endroits où les
envois c'est dans des zones bien
précises
là par exemple on a trois
beat c'est à dire 3 région bien précise
autour de la terre où on envoie des
satellites vous avez la zone les eaux
qui veut dire orbite basse terrestre où
on en voit plutôt des satellites pour
observer la terre en mai où la zone
intermédiaire où on en voit plutôt des
satellites de navigation et la zone géo
où on en voit plutôt les satellites de
télécommunications et ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que les d'evry également en
différentes origines
parmi les plus gros débris vous avez des
satellites
donc c'est déjà dit qu'ils sont à la
retraite mais il faut de carburant les
laisse en eau parce que voilà c'est trop
difficile de les faire rentrer sur terre
vous avez également des morceaux de
fusées parce que lorsqu'on envoie un
satellite dans l'espace
et bien la fusée qui nous transporte se
disloque au fur et à mesure qu'elle
monte en altitude et les morceaux de
fusées qui protège de satellite ne s'en
sépare qu'une fois arrivés hors de la
terre c'est à dire dans l'espace il y
reste
et parmi les plus petits débris vous
avez les écailles de peinture et ses
écailles de peinture viennent également
des morceaux de fusées et des satellites
qui sont restés vains mots aujourd'hui
la source majeure de création de débris
spatiaux
en fait c'est deux événements on les
appelle événements de fragmentation
c'est la collision et l'explosion à eux
seuls ils génèrent la moitié des débris
spatiaux qu'on a aujourd'hui on prend
l'exemple d'une collision deux objets
rentrer en collision
des débris sont créés ces débris tourne
autour de la terre et à leur tour ces
nouveaux débris peuvent rentrer en
collision avec d'autres objets de
nouveaux débris sont générés ils vont à
leur tour entre en collision avec
d'autres objets et cetera et cetera
c'est donc une réaction en chaîne qu'on
a et qu'il ne connaît pas forcément de
faim ce qui veut dire également c'est
que même si aujourd'hui on arrêtait
d'envoyer des objets dans l'espace
le nombre de débris spatiaux ne se
serait d'augmenter
juste parce à sa part cette réaction en
chaîne
vous ai dit qu'il y avait des débris qui
font à peine 1 cm 1 cm 11 x et pas
beaucoup mais un des prix d'un
centimètre ça fait mal parce que là où
il a une vitesse qui est assez
importante
tellement importante que un livret d'un
centimètre c'est comme si c'était une
enclume qui arrivait sur vous et pour
les gens dans la salle qui sont
parisiens vous pourrez voir ça tous les
jours pour ceux qui ne sont pas feints
crois qu'en france partout il ya des bus
ans je crois quoi qu'il en soit quand
vous verrez un bus dites vous que ce bus
c'est comme un débris spatial qu'à une
taille de 5 cm et imaginé ce bus qui
rentrent qui voulait lui bah ça ça fait
mal on est en fait une travail de
recherche
c'est mon travail de thèse je travaille
sur les événements de fragmentation dans
mon bureau je fais des collisions enfin
je simule des collisions et explosions
son ordinateur pour voir combien de
débris sont générés et comment ils vont
évoluer autour de la terre et en plus je
vais jouer avec plusieurs paramètres
pour voir leur influence
par exemple pour une vitesse de 3 km par
seconde
ou alors 8 km par seconde comment des
des prix vont être généré comment ils
vont se former autour de la terre ce que
reprend mon exemple de la collision lors
d'une collision un instant très près un
instant très proche de la collision et
d'evry sont concentrés dans une dans une
région avec le temps ils vont former une
forme de tore autour de la terre et
quelques temps après ils ont emmené une
bande autour de la terre est bien le
problème c'est que lorsqu'on a une
collision en général c'était centaines
voire des milliers d'objets qui sont
générés ça fait beaucoup à gérer en même
temps
donc du coup une partie de ma thèse
c'est de voir s'il existe une méthode
qui pourrait nous permettre de les
suivre en tant qu'ensemble et non pas 1
et donc j'ai commencé à regarder dans
mes bouquins de mécanique céleste et
mécanique céleste c'est la matière dans
laquelle on prend toutes les équations
et théorique nous permettent d'être
didier la trajectoire le mouvement d'un
objet dans l'espace je n'ai pas trouvé
de réponse
donc du coup je parle surteintées voir
ailleurs et j'ai trouvé une réponse dans
la mécanique des fluides la mécanique
des fluides ses lectures du comportement
d'un liquide ou d'un gaz comme l'eau par
exemple et quand j'ai trouvé cette
méthode c'est là que je me suis dit mais
c'est pour ça que j'aime la recherche
scientifique
parce qu'en fait on cherche des fois on
ne trouve pas c'est dommage mais on est
obligé de sortir des carcans de son
domaine de spécialité pour trouver une
solution et c'est dansant en fait que je
me vois pour plus tard la recherche
scientifique et ma thèse c'est que la
première étape en fait le saut rêve
depuis quelques années j'ai
l'opportunité de voyager en france ou à
l'étranger pour pouvoir regarder deux
magnifiques ce qu'ils étoilé et
aujourd'hui je me rends compte que
j'avais un regard aveugle un fait social
parce que il y avait des objets qui
passait rapidement et ces objets ce les
débris spatiaux et je me disais même
incident pareil on arrive à le produit
est ma thèse me fait comprendre qu'eux
mêmes ont passé que même si ma
contribution ne sera pas très grande que
je ferai tout pour pouvoir y contribuer
et surtout faire en sorte que vous
également puissiez profiter d'un skate
pareil avec vos proches avec ceux qui
vous sont chers et surtout par
génération suivante
merci